five years to Black tap Las Vegas you
know the the burger and milkshake Heaven
can I say that because it really is I
mean it's a Burger milkshake Wonderland
general manager Andrew gullickson is
here to show us how they're celebrating
the big five how are you great thanks
for having me oh please it is my
pleasure I'm so glad that I got this
interview because I love this meal that
we're about to talk about yes ma'am but
first I want to say happy five years how
were the first five years first five
years have been great thanks to our
locals and our customer base and we just
look forward to serving everyone else
absolutely now um before we get to the
meal I want to pop up a special photo we
have it there
because he was coming to town and I
figured brother Burgers champagne
milkshakes it was perfect for him we'd
love to see that thank you for coming of
course let's talk about the menu because
this is something that was during
December during the actual anniversary
but you guys are keeping the party going
through January we are continuing
through January we have our filet
truffle uh champagne burger that I'm
going to show you guys how to make today
you take your six ounce Creek Stone
filet you put it right there on the bun
we have our truffle champagne cream
sauce that goes over the burger
delicious you want to get a lot of it on
there
um you got our Tallow fries that go on
top gives it a nice beautiful Crunch and
then on our Bun over here we have our
black pepper peppercorn aioli and all
these different flavors that are going
together my herbs there and then we got
to put our Tallow fries on the plate as
well which yellow fries are fried and
beef fat basically which are delicious
and Rocky if you can help me out with
topping those off maybe I got you I got
you beautiful now this is the this is
the meal but we have a minute so I want
to make sure we get to the Truffle part
of it yes yes we have and then
absolutely have our truffles that finish
the burger at the end yeah because that
is special each one has uh some of our
winter black truffles that go over the
top we put four on each and then also we
have our Tallow fries that get the the
truffles as well I love this and last
but not least everybody tell everybody
about your crazy Shake Bar and as I you
know absolutely this is our crazy uh our
champagne uh strawberry Crazy Shake It
is a celebration she's going to try it
that was close oh that was not good I'm
better at drinking the shake I'm better
at drinking the shake and then inside of
it we put that puppy okay beautiful
and that is a champagne strawberry ice
pop that we make at home and then you
put some of that over the top and while
I while we finish this lock I want
everybody to know this is obviously not
a vegan dish but vegan it is veganuary
we do have vegan items and we are
celebrating vegan area coming in uh
February so we will have several more
vegan items wow well if you have never
been to blacktop it is awesome you guys
have to go take the whole family have
fun and thank you cheers to five years
five more enjoy all right